Welcome again to another bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎再次收听《如何制作你的老妈》的又一期特别节目。
It's our final bonus episode before we launch season two towards the end of October.
这是我们在十月下旬推出第二季之前的最后一期特别节目。
In this upcoming season, we've already got a bunch of special guests lined up and a very special announcement about our podcast, which I'm just not quite allowed to announce right now.
在即将到来的这一季中，我们已经安排了一群特邀嘉宾，还有一个关于我们播客的特别公告，目前我还不能直接公布。
So stay tuned to the internet.
所以请大家密切关注网络上的动态。
This week, we bring you an interview that I did on the new podcast, The Craft of Being, hosted by Anna Schumacher.
本周，我们为你带来一段采访，这是我做客安娜·舒马赫（Anna Schumacher）的新播客《创作的本质》（The Craft of Being）时进行的。
The craft of being is a podcast via a series of conversations where Anna digs into the question, what the heck even is creativity?
《创作的本质》是一个通过一系列坦诚对话展开的播客，安娜在其中深入探讨了一个问题：究竟什么是创造力？
I got a chance to talk to her about producing the podcast and working with Josh and Craig and then we go into other projects I've been involved with throughout the years.
我有机会与她聊了聊制作播客的经历、与乔什和克雷格的合作，然后我们还谈到了我多年来参与过的一些其他项目。
You can listen to the craft of being wherever you get your podcasts and there's even a link in our show notes.
你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听《创作的本质》，我们的节目简介里甚至还有一个链接。
Also, fun fact, Anna's voice can be heard in the opening montage of Hymmium fan voices in the very first episode of How We Made Your Mother.
另外，趣事分享：安娜的声音出现在了《如何制作你的老妈》第一集片头蒙太奇中那些粉丝的声音里。
And now, The Craft of Being.
接下来，让我们进入《创作的本质》。
Hi, hello, and welcome to another episode of The Craft of Being.
嗨，你好，欢迎收听《创作的本质》的又一期节目。
This is a podcast by way of a series of candid conversations where we dig into what the heck even is creativity.
这是一个通过一系列坦诚对话展开的播客，我们在其中深入探讨究竟什么是创造力。
Undefined yet definitive.
它既未被定义，却又无比明确。
We will talk about the types of of innate creative muscles that live within all of us, within you, yes, you.
我们将探讨存在于我们所有人内心的那些与生俱来的创作力量，存在于你——是的，就是你——内心的力量。
And we will talk about how these creative muscles evolve with us across life, work, art, and the pursuit of everything.
我们还将探讨这些创作力量如何在我们的生活、工作、艺术以及对万物的追求中与我们一起进化。
Today we're gonna chat about film and podcast media.
今天我们要聊的是电影和播客媒体。
My guest today is well-versed in both, he wears many hats, and our conversation takes us through the systems that support and interact with the artistry.
我今天的嘉宾对这两者都非常精通，他身兼数职，我们的对话将带我们领略那些支持并与艺术创作产生互动的体系。
Across the board, there's this kind of double consciousness in the way artistic, creative work finds its way into the world.
总体而言，艺术和创意作品走向世界的方式中，存在着一种双重意识。
On one side, there's the intensity of the creative work itself, the hours of writing, rehearsing, shooting, editing, stitching together details until they finally resolve into something coherent.
一方面，是创作工作本身的强度：数小时的写作、排练、拍摄、剪辑，将细节一点点缝合，直到它们最终凝聚成连贯的作品。
On the other side, there is the preparation, the scaffolding of validation, the decks, the pitches, the budgets, the endless, like me, trust me, gestures.
另一方面，是筹备工作、获得认可的支撑结构、方案书、推介演说、预算，以及无数诸如“相信我，相信我”之类的姿态。
You'll hear Alec talk about that, that are required before many projects can even begin.
你会听到亚历克谈到这一点，这是许多项目启动前所必需的。
And by begin, I mean here, begin with the goal of being seen, being picked up, becoming the thing that launches someone into a place where the work can speak for itself and that someone can keep working in this stream so far as capitalism runs the game, okay?
我说的启动，是指带着被看到、被买下、成为能让某人的作品自己说话并在这个资本主义规则统治的行业里继续工作下去的跳板这一目标的启动，好吧？
Hollywood, Hollywood, has built an empire on this double consciousness.
好莱坞，好莱坞正是建立在双重意识的帝国之上。
It is a city where art and commerce are bound together so tightly that they appear inseparable where the beauty of a scene and the pressure of an opening weekend are measured on the same ledger.
这是一座艺术与商业紧密交织、几乎不可分割的城市，在这里，一个场景的美感与首周末票房的压力在同一本账目上被衡量。
To speak about Hollywood is to speak about an entire architecture of creativity, a system that provides opportunity and exposure, and also dictates form funding and legitimacy.
谈论好莱坞，就是在谈论一整套创造力的建筑学——一个既提供机会与曝光，同时也决定了形式、资金与合法性的系统。
A film is not simply the work of its director and cast.
一部电影不仅仅是导演和演员的工作。
It's also the work of financiers, distributors, marketing teams, and executives who determine and whether the work will even see the light of day.
它也是出资人、发行商、营销团队和高管的工作，他们决定着这部作品能否重见天日。
This structure is at once enabling and constraining.
这种结构既是赋能的，也是限制的。
It allows something as vast and complex as a feature film to even exist, but it also requires the artist to frame their own imagination in ways that appeal to some gatekeepers.
它让像长片这样宏大复杂的作品得以存在，但也要求艺术家用能够吸引某些守门人的方式来构筑自己的想象力。
The Creative Act begins long before a camera rolls, right?
创意行为远在摄像机开拍之前就已经开始了，对吧？
It begins in the translation of vision into the pitch deck, into the log line, into a concise justification of why the work deserves to exist.
它始于将愿景转化为推介案（pitch deck）、一句话梗概（log line），以及对作品为什么值得存在的简洁论证。
The podcast world has inherited many of the same dynamics.
播客世界继承了许多相同的动态。
Just like Tarantino once used to be able to make reservoir dogs in a warehouse on a whisper in a dream, so too can I sit here in our tiny spare room that quadruples as bicycle storage in my desk in a dumping space for outdoor gear and toddler toys and put my thoughts in craft out there.
正如昆汀过去曾能凭着一个梦想的低语，在仓库里拍出《落水狗》一样，我也能坐在这个身兼四职的小备用房间里——它既是自行车储藏室，也是我办公桌的所在地，还是户外装备和幼儿玩具的堆放区——把我的思想和手艺呈现出去。
Though I don't have Harvey Keitel, and thus it's just you and me.
虽然我没有哈威·凯特尔，所以这里只有你和我。
What might have once seemed like a freer medium, just pressed record, let the conversation flow, upload it for anyone to hear, has quickly developed its own economies of scale, its own validation structures.
曾经看似更自由的媒介——只需按下录音键，让对话自然流淌，然后上传供任何人收听——现在已经迅速发展出其自身的规模经济和认可结构。
A podcast needs a host, yes, but it also needs production schedules, advertising partnerships, distribution platforms, and metrics that prove value.
一个播客需要主持人，没错，但它也需要制作日程、广告合作、分发平台以及证明其价值的数据指标。
Behind every hour of conversation released into the world are countless invisible acts of coordination, emails, calendars, edits, sponsorship copies, social media prompts.
在向世界发布的每一个小时对话背后，都有无数看不见的协调工作：电子邮件、日历、剪辑、赞助文案、社交媒体文案。
The work disappears into the final product and yet it is essential to the very possibility of the show.
这些工作消失在了最终的产品中，然而它们对于节目能够存在本身却至关重要。
To be clear, I am all of the roles and we do not have a sponsorship department.
需要说明的是，我一人兼顾了所有角色，我们并没有专门的赞助部门。
There is a paradox of much of modern artistic creativity.
现代艺术创作中存在着这样一个悖论。
The most ephemeral media often require the most relentless scaffolding.
最瞬息万变的媒介往往需要最不懈的支撑结构。
Episodes vanish into a stream, but the labor that sustains them is constant.
单集节目消失在信息流中，但维持它们运转的劳作却是恒常的。
Movies may be remembered for decades, but before they can exist, they must pass through this obstacle course.
电影可能会被人们铭记几十年，但在它们得以存在之前，必须通过这道障碍赛。
In both cases for film and podcasting, the act of creation is inseparable from the structures that allow it to reach an audience.
无论是电影还是播客，创作行为都与让它触及受众的结构密不可分。
There's something instructive in noticing how creators move between these systems.
观察创作者如何在这些系统之间穿梭，具有某种启发意义。
Directing a film and producing a podcast may seem like entirely different crafts yet they share a common rhythm.
执导电影和制作播客似乎是完全不同的手艺，但它们却有着共同的节奏。
Establish the outline, the framework, set the stage, line up the ducks, and then let the unpredictable alchemy of collaboration bring something to life.
建立大纲、框架，搭建舞台，把事情安排妥当，然后让不可预测的合作炼金术将某些东西带入现实。
A director can block a scene, but the actors will always bring their own nuance.
导演可以为场景走位，但演员总会带来他们自己的细微差别。
A producer can schedule the recording, but the conversation will always unfold in ways that no outline can fully anticipate.
制作人可以安排录音时间，但对话的展开方式永远是任何大纲都无法完全预料的。
Creativity, as we've heard on many of these episodes, so often thrives at the junction of order and play.
正如我们在许多节目中听到的一样，创造力往往在秩序与游戏的交汇处蓬勃发展。
In today's conversation, we get into the way projects are set up.
在今天的对话中，我们深入探讨了项目的筹备方式。
Spreadsheets, fun spreadsheets, sequences of scenes ordered and reordered, and then the joy of stepping back to watch collaborators bring the unexpected.
电子表格，有趣的电子表格，按顺序排列又重新排序的场景序列，然后是退后一步，看着合作伙伴带来意想不到惊喜的喜悦。
And what emerges is the broader truth about film, television, podcasting, creativity itself, that it oscillates between the structure and flow.
由此浮现的是关于电影、电视、播客以及创造力本身的更广泛真理：它在结构与流动之间摇摆。
Too much order, the work becomes lifeless, too much freedom, the work risks in coherence.
秩序太多，作品就会变得毫无生气；自由太多，作品则面临逻辑不清的风险。
This is not a lament.
这不是一种哀叹。
It is a recognition that modern creativity is always entangled with its systems of distribution and visibility.
这是一种认同，即现代创造力总是与其分发和曝光系统纠缠在一起。
To make something is also to navigate the infrastructures that allow it to be seen, heard, or streamed, experienced.
创作某物，同时也意味着驾驭那些让它得以被看到、被听到、被流媒体播放或被体验的基础设施。
here today that my guest, Alec, reflects that this negotiation is not a distraction from his creativity.
今天在这里，我的嘉宾亚历克反思道，这种协商并不是对他创造力的分散。
It is creativity.
这就是创造力本身。
To build a schedule that makes weekly episodes possible to reorder sequences in a screenplay until they lock into place, to coordinate your collaborators.
构建使每周播客成为可能的时间表，在剧本中重新排序场景直到它们锁定到位，协调你的合作伙伴。
These are acts of invention.
这些都是发明的行为。
So to hear him in his own words, without further ado, welcome to the show.
废话不多说，让我们听听他自己的肺腑之言，欢迎来到本节目。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Baseball.
棒球。
I'm talking about baseball.
我指的是棒球。
You've been called up.
你被征召了。
You're I've been taught, I'm a put me in coach, I am ready to play.
我被告知，我是那种“教练请让我上场，我已经准备好比赛了”的人。
Excellent, well please introduce yourself, what's your name?
太好了，那么请自我介绍一下，你叫什么名字？
What do you do and how do we know each other?
你是做什么的？我们是怎么认识的？
My name is Alec Lev, I am a director and a producer, I'm going to go with that.
我叫亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev），我是一名导演兼制作人，我倾向于这么称呼自己。
And we know each other, well we met twice, I would say at least, we in other lives definitely passed and vaguely present for me.
至于我们怎么认识的，嗯，我们至少见过两次面，在其他人生阶段我们肯定有过交集，对我来说有些依稀模糊但确实存在。
We are we're sign language interpreters and we interpret it at the Marlton School for the Deaf.
我们曾是手语翻译，我们在马尔顿聋哑学校（Marlton School for the Deaf）担任翻译。
I say this with I was gonna say great confidence with near confidence but it should be known that years later you through a mutual friend you hired me to direct some public service videos, I think we call them.
我本想说我对此有着十足的信心，其实是差不多的信心，但大家应该知道，多年后你通过一位共同的朋友雇我导演了一些公共服务视频，我想我们当时是这么叫它们的。
And I don't remember exactly but the meeting probably went something like where I said, hi, nice to meet you.
我不记得具体细节了，但那次会面大概是这样的情景：我说，嗨，很高兴认识你。
And you said something like you idiot, we met.
而你说：你个白痴，我们早就认识了。
I think we called them tone poems at one point.
我想我们在某个阶段把它们叫做音诗（tone poems）。
Can you expand a little bit on what it is that you produce and or direct?
你能详细谈谈你制作或导演的内容吗？
Sure.
当然。
So as we speak, I am producing the podcast How We Made Your Mother, which is a rewatch podcast of the hit television show, How We Met Your Mother.
录制这期节目时，我正在制作播客《如何制作你的老妈》，这是一档重温热播电视剧《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的播客。
I can't even say the name of the show anymore.
我现在甚至都说不对这部剧的名字了。
How I met your mother, that's the TV show.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，那是这部电视剧。
And our podcast is with The Eye and How I Met Your Mother, Josh Radner, and the co-creator of the show, Craig Thomas, with whom I went to Wesleyan back in the day.
我们的播客嘉宾有乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radnor）——剧中的“我”——以及该剧的联合创作者克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas），我和他当年在卫斯理大学（Wesleyan）是校友。
so we've been great friends for decades and I worked on the show for a little bit back when it was on and so I'm producing that now and I've produced a couple of other podcasts meeting Tom Cruise, people telling insane stories about how they met Tom Cruise and as a director I have done a lot of theater I was a theater major like you I was a theater major back in college and I've done a bunch of directly mostly with deaf theaters.
所以我们是几十年的好朋友，当年该剧播出时我也参与过制作，所以我现在在制作这个播客。我还制作过其他几档播客，比如《遇见汤姆·克鲁斯》（meeting Tom Cruise），讲述人们如何偶遇汤姆·克鲁斯的疯狂故事。作为一名导演，我做过很多戏剧，我大学时的主修专业是戏剧，就像你一样，我大学时也是戏剧专业，我导演过很多作品，主要是与聋哑剧团合作。
I guess we can talk about that.
我想我们可以聊聊这个。
And then I directed a couple of films, one of which you produced.
然后我还导演了几部电影，其中有一部是你担任制作人的。
And you and I, as of this recording, are gunning towards the next collaboration that I will direct and you will produce again.
截至录制时，你和我正准备开启下一次合作，我将担任导演，而你将再次担任制作人。
Then the question I always ask everyone is, do you feel like a creative person?
那么我经常问大家的一个问题是：你觉得自己是一个有创造力的人吗？
I better.
我最好是。
Yes.
是的。
I have no caveats to that whatsoever.
对此我没有任何保留条件。
Yes, that is the only thing I'm interested in doing professionally and I don't even call it professionally really.
是的，这是我职业生涯中唯一感兴趣的事情，甚至连“职业生涯”这个词我都觉得不太准确。
It's what I want to do when I wake up and it almost doesn't matter the form that is I enjoy the act of directing the most like all the things I'm doing those few hours after so many months or years of preparation when I'm actually just there doing the directing thing that's the most fun but I love directing and producing and editing and writing and just sitting around coming up with stories so all of it yes so the caveat if there there were one is I think it would have been harder for me not that long ago to proudly declare on a podcast, I am a creator, I am an artist, that kind of thing.
这是我醒来后想做的事情，至于它的形式几乎不重要，我最享受导演这个行为本身——在经历了数月甚至数年的筹备之后，在实际进行导演工作的这几个小时里，那是最好玩的部分。但我热爱导演、制作、剪辑、写作，以及坐在一起构思故事，所以这一切，是的。如果有任何保留条件的话，那就是不久前，我可能很难在播客中自豪地宣布：我是一个创作者，我是一个艺术家，诸如此类。
But maybe it was passing my 50th birthday, we're like, I gotta be something.
但也许是迈过50岁生日让我觉得：我总得是个什么身份吧。
And so sure, let's go with artists to create stuff, yeah.
所以好吧，那就当个创造东西的艺术家吧，是的。
That's great.
太棒了。
Right, there's also the aspect of all of this that we talk about fairly often, which is where my friend Kit put this very well, where art and commerce are uneasy bedfellows, she said, which I love because that is always playing in the back of your mind when you are thinking how can I be the version of myself that I love the most and that I am the best for other people while also keeping the lights on to my house and feeding my children, which is I should do that, right?
没错，我们经常谈论的这一切中还有一个方面，我朋友基特（Kit）对此有一个非常精辟的概括，她说艺术与商业是勉强成婚的同床异梦者，我非常喜欢这句话，因为当你考虑如何成为自己最喜爱、对别人最有价值的那个版本，同时还要付清房租、喂饱孩子们时，这种想法总是盘旋在你的脑海里，而我确实应该这么做，对吧？
How do I was forgetting to do something?
我刚刚是不是忘了做什么事？
Been doing it.
其实一直在做。
You and I and our collaborator, Josh, are working on something right now, and I think all three of us are loving every step of the way in what we're writing as an act of creation, as an act of writing.
你、我和我们的合作伙伴乔什目前正在合作一个项目，我想我们三个人都非常享受我们正在编写的作为创作行为、作为写作行为的每一步。
When we get together and do it, when we do it separately, I think we're enjoying that moment just in and of itself and all of course the back of our heads is Also because it means one day we'll get to make the damn thing.
当我们聚在一起创作，或是各自独立创作时，我想我们都在单纯地享受那个时刻，当然，我们脑海深处也盘旋着另一个原因，那就是这意味着总有一天我们能把这个该死的东西拍出来。
I think our collaborative Dynamic the three of us is a good example.
我认为我们三个人之间的协作动态就是一个很好的例子。
What happens a lot of places in created projects or art projects where you have You figure out where each of your creative skill sets kind of lock into the larger picture For example, during our recent writer's retreat, there was the kind of messier version of like, oh, and then they should, and then they shouldn't.
在很多创意项目或艺术项目中，经常发生的情况是：你要弄清楚你们各自的创意技能如何契合到宏大的画卷中。例如，在我们最近的编剧闭关期间，就有一种比较混乱的情况，比如，哦，然后他们应该这样，然后他们不应该这样。
And then you're there with the laptop being like, let's talk about the actual sequence number and the actual places goes, we're moving this here.
然后你拿着笔记本电脑坐在那儿，像是说，让我们来讨论一下实际的场景编号以及具体的位置，我们要把这个移到这里。
And that's where the different skill sets and interests and where people tend to like to be creative, get to come together and make something cohesive.
这就是不同的技能、兴趣以及人们倾向于展现创造力的地方汇聚在一起，并创造出有凝聚力的东西的过程。
Right, though, I think I have pulled the two of you into my evil realm of enjoying those numbers also.
没错，不过我想我已经把你们两个拉进了我那也喜欢数字的邪恶领域。
I think that for both of you that's not your tendency necessarily, you're not that kind of spreadsheet head quite that I am.
我觉得对你们俩来说，这未必是你们的天性，你们不像我那样是个表格控。
We're also dealing with something so complicated structurally that it's part of it.
我们也在处理结构上非常复杂的事情，这也是其中的一部分。
Putting them in a certain order is part of it.
把它们按一定的顺序排列也是其中的一部分。
But for sure, yes, we each tend towards a slightly different side of things, though there are definitely collaborations that are exciting because the collaborators work so differently.
但可以肯定的是，是的，我们每个人都倾向于事情略有不同的侧面，尽管确实有些合作非常令人兴奋，因为合作者的工作方式截然不同。
I think we're freakishly on the same page.
我觉得我们在这一点上出奇地意见一致。
I look forward to the explosion.
我很期待那场爆发。
I look forward to it.
我很期待。
We're just like, fuck this.
我们当时就像是，去他的。
And someone throws a digital piece of paper down on the ground, walks away and says, this is over.
然后有人把一张数字化的纸扔在地上，走开并说，这结束了。
Until now, it's been lovely.
到目前为止，一切都很美好。
I'm not looking forward to that actually at all, I don't want this at all.
其实我一点也不期待那个，我一点也不想要这个。
The podcast, which is available by the way, anywhere that podcasts are, I mean, anywhere that podcasts are available, you can listen to Howie Major Mother.
顺便说一句，这个播客在任何可以收听播客的地方都可以听到，我是说，在任何可以收听播客的地方，你都可以收听 Howie Major Mother。
The merch is there too, don't worry about it.
周边商品也在那里，不用担心。
The role of producing something like that, which has lots of moving parts, is a little bit like it's um it is kind of finding a constant order within the chaos definitely that there is someone over here doing something someone over here doing something they all don't know what the other vegetable in the soup thank you is doing and i the chef or the person eating the soup why am i doing this i am the only one that sees the whole soup stop and i like that i enjoy that i I definitely enjoy pulling all those pieces together, getting them in order, making sure that A is talking to B.
制作诸如此类有许多活动部件的东西的角色，有点像是……它确实是在混乱中寻找持续的秩序，肯定会有人在这里做点什么，有人在那里做点什么，他们都不知道汤里的其他蔬菜——谢谢——在做什么，而我这个厨师或喝汤的人——我为什么要在做这个？——我是唯一一个能看到整锅汤的人。停下，我喜欢这样，我享受这个，我绝对享受把所有这些碎片拼凑在一起，把它们按顺序排列，确保A和B能够沟通。
But I also, and I guess if you were to walk into a new project that had not been yours and you had to walk into chaos and organize it, I'm down with that.
但我也，我想如果你走进一个不是你自己的新项目，而你必须走进混乱并将其组织起来，我是支持的。
I'm a step-by-step kind of person.
我是那种一步一个脚印的人。
Well, I'm gonna challenge you on this, sir, because the feature film that I produced nebulously produced because as I'm going to describe it, how did you produce a thing that didn't exist until it existed?
好吧，我要在这点上挑战你，先生，因为我制作的那部故事片——可以说是模糊地制作，因为正如我要描述的，你怎么能制作一个在它存在之前并不存在的东西呢？
But no plans this weekend was all about we're gonna go into this place with absolutely no plan and we just so happen to have a cast full of obscenely talented people who are going to kind of make this whole thing connect together.
但《这周末没计划》讲的就是我们要毫无计划地进入这个地方，而且我们恰好有一群才华横溢得离谱的演员，他们将把整件事情串联起来。
But we went into that without an idea.
但我们在毫无头绪的情况下就进去了。
And it was the structure and the dream around the chaos that was there to hold it, but everything that happened on the day was really just spaghetti, spaghetti everywhere on every wall.
正是混乱周围的结构和梦想支撑着它，但当天发生的每件事真的就像意大利面一样，每面墙上到处都是意大利面。
So we, yes, we shot a film called though plans this weekend presents Breakdown.
所以我们，对，我们这周末拍了一部名为《虽然计划》由Present Breakdown呈现的电影。
And we arrived on a sound stage that had 12, 13 standing sets with a group of seven or eight actors.
我们到了一个有12、13个固定布景的摄影棚，还有七八个演员。
And we literally had no scripts, no characters, no story, absolutely zero, zero, nothing.
我们真的没有剧本，没有角色，没有故事，绝对是零，零，什么都没有。
And we on the first day, we just got the group together, walked around and our collaborator, Josh, who we knew would be the lead.
第一天我们把大家聚在一起，四处走走，还有我们的合作者乔什，我们知道他会是主角。
I'm sorry, that is one thing that we just decided.
不好意思，这是我们刚刚决定的一件事。
Josh came up with an idea right away.
乔什马上想出了一个点子。
We're like, Okay, pretty much said, Okay, that's the movie.
我们就觉得，好吧，差不多就是，好吧，这就是这部电影。
And then we made scene by scene and we shot behind the scenes of it.
然后我们一幕一幕地拍，还拍了幕后花絮。
So you get to see that whole process.
所以你们能看到整个过程。
I always knew it would be a bunch of scenes that were going to tell a story and there'd be a behind the scenes aspect to it.
我一直都知道它会是一堆讲述故事的场景，并且会有一个幕后花絮的方面。
So very, very ordered chaos was that.
所以那真的是非常有秩序的混乱。
And I would say that I in I love that more than anything I've ever done for sure.
而且我要说，我绝对比我做过的任何事情都更喜欢这个。
And it because actually it fits what you were talking about, which is as we know right now on the new movie, we are writing words on the page.
而且因为它实际上符合你刚才所说的，正如我们现在所知道的，在新电影中，我们正在纸上写台词。
Human beings have to speak words.
人类必须说出这些话。
We've been developing this for a couple of months and now our characters we have to just make them talk and I'm enjoying question mark the words that I'm putting down on the page to make the humans talk to each other but I also know that getting these improvisers into that room they were definitely going to come up with funnier things than I when I was writing it down so the idea of of each person in the collaboration, having their own skill that you lean on and don't think, oh, I wish I could be doing that.
我们已经筹备了几个月，现在我们的角色，我们必须让他们开口说话，我正在享受（问号）我写在纸上让人们互相交流的话，但我也知道让这些即兴表演者进入那个房间，他们绝对会想出比我写下来时更有趣的事情，所以合作中的每个人都有自己赖以倚重、不用去想“哦，我希望我也能做那个”的技能。
Like, I don't wish I could be doing that.
就像，我不希望我能做那个一样。
The people we worked with are better than me at the doing of that.
我们合作的人在这方面比我更擅长。
And so again, it's very, very ordered chaos as chaos goes.
所以再次说明，就混乱而言，这是非常非常有秩序的混乱。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
This is why we're not writing a comedy.
这就是为什么我们不写喜剧。
Are we not?
我们不是吗？
Wait a second, we're not writing.
等等，我们没有在写。
So he should not have the clown nose.
所以他不应该戴小丑鼻子。
I didn't, I wasn't sure if I should keep the clown nose?
我不知道，我不确定我是不是该留着小丑鼻子？
No.
不。
We're tossing it.
我们要把它扔了。
The tiny car stays.
那辆小车留着。
I want to walk back and talk about do you remember when in your life you first felt like creativity mattered to you what that felt like like even a sense memory of that?
我想往回聊聊，你还记得你人生中是什么时候第一次觉得创造力对你很重要吗？那种感觉是怎样的，哪怕只是一种触觉记忆？
There was definitely in I want to call it kindergarten someone was making a film we were making a film and when I say film it might have even been on film.
我绝对记得，我想那是在幼儿园吧，有人在拍电影，我们在拍电影——当我说电影时，它甚至可能是胶片拍的。
This was a while ago now.
这已经是好久以前的事了。
But it was all done.
但它全部完成了。
It was all stop motion.
全都是定格动画。
I think it was all stop motion of memory serves.
如果我没记错的话，我想全都是定格动画。
And I think the character I drew was like a magician.
我想我画的角色像个魔术师。
So that's a deep cut there that I like to make the magic happen there.
所以那是一个很深的情结，我喜欢让魔法在那里发生。
But I do remember seeing the miracle of that.
但我确实记得见证了那种奇迹。
I don't remember thinking any other way.
我不记得自己有过别的想法。
There wasn't any other thing I was really interested in ever.
从来没有什么别的事情让我真正感兴趣过。
I liked math for a while but that wasn't like going to I wasn't gonna career myself through math and now I have my spreadsheets as a producer so I need my math but I don't remember thinking another way.
我有一段时间喜欢数学，但那可不会成为——我不会靠数学来开启职业生涯，现在作为制片人我有我的电子表格，所以我也需要数学，但我不记得自己有过别的想法。
It was always making stuff and play acting and Star Wars was a huge part of it.
一直都是在做东西、过家家，而《星球大战》占了很大一部分。
Star Wars I was born in 1975 and so and I have a I think I have a memory of seeing Star Wars episode 4 in the theater certainly Return of the Jedi, certainly Empire Strikes Back, and then Indiana Jones, then Return of the Jedi.
《星球大战》——我出生于1975年，所以我——我想我有在电影院看《星球大战》第四部（新希望）的记忆，当然还有《绝地归来》、《帝国反击战》，然后是《夺宝奇兵》，接着是《绝地归来》。
So I was like, I was all in on movies, very, very early, they were everything.
所以我可以说是非常、非常早就全心投入到电影中去了，电影就是我的一切。
And then I started...
然后我开始……
It sounds like you're all in on Harrison Ford, specifically.
听起来你是全心全意迷上了哈里森·福特，具体来说。
A little bit on Harrison Ford.
有点迷哈里森·福特。
Witness was very big in my life.
在我生活中非常重要。
Dying young, it was very important to me as a young child.
（Dying Young），作为一个小孩子，它对我很重要。
Keep going, this is a litmus test right now.
继续，这现在是个试金石。
K9 was a big one.
（K-9）是一部很重要的作品。
But playing with Star Wars figures was a full-time job.
不过，玩《星球大战》玩偶是一份全职工作。
up and making up those stories with those figures and imbuing them with personalities that weren't necessarily from the movies.
摆弄着它们，用那些玩偶编造故事，并赋予它们不一定来自电影的个性。
Huge part of storytelling growing up.
这是成长过程中讲故事的巨大一部分。
You touched on before your role as a podcast producer for how we made your mother the re-watch podcast for how I'm a mother.
你刚才提到了你作为播客制作人的角色，比如你是如何制作《老爸老妈的浪漫史》重看播客的。
There's merch, what t-shirt.
有周边，什么T恤。
But I am hoping you can expand a little bit on what the tasks and creative solutioning you do for the average life cycle of a show from making to posting.
但我希望你能稍微扩展一下，从制作到发布，一档节目的平均生命周期里，你都要做什么任务以及进行怎样的创意解决。
Sure.
当然。
It's a great collaboration.
这是一次很棒的合作。
I mean, ultimately, truly, and I have no reason to puff myself down.
我是说，归根结底，真的，我没有理由贬低自己。
Can you do that?
你能做到吗？
I mean, the reason you're just gonna enjoy that is because you're gonna love listening to these two guys talk.
我是说，你之所以会喜欢这样，是因为你会喜欢听这两个家伙聊天。
And we could just press record and then I could post the thing that they said.
我们本来可以随便按个录音键，然后把他们说的话发出去就行了。
But I do think of each episode as a tiny little work of art and it's not a work of anything else, so it's gotta be that.
但我确实把每一集都当成一件小小的艺术品，它不可能是别的什么东西，所以它必须是这样。
And so it involves we planning a little bit.
所以这需要我们做一点计划。
And when I say planning, I mean scheduling, getting us all in the same place.
当我说计划时，我的意思是安排日程，把我们所有人聚在同一个地方。
And that involves many phone calls and many emails and assistance and calendars and all that.
这涉及到许多电话、许多电子邮件、助理和日历等等。
And so, okay, that's the first part, not wildly thrilling, but you gotta do that.
所以，好吧，这是第一部分，虽然算不上惊心动魄，但你必须得做。
You get in the same place.
你们聚在同一个地方。
We record ads.
我们录制广告。
We have to think about, oh, three weeks from now, I actually need this one piece.
我们得考虑，哦，从现在起三周后，我其实需要这个片段。
So we're going to record this little thing now too, so you're puzzling that out as you think about a full season.
所以我们现在也要把这个小片段录下来，当你在考虑整个季度时，你得把这些拼凑起来。
We do, we have about 22 week season, but actually maybe 40 episodes within those weeks.
我们做过，我们有一个大约22周的季度，但实际上在这几周里可能有40集。
And so I'm planning a little bit in advance.
所以我得提前做点计划。
We do special episodes where people ask questions, so I have to go on to the internet and ask people questions.
我们还会做人们提问的特别节目，所以我必须上网向大家征集问题。
And there's a creative moment there where I post a little square on Instagram.
这里有一个创意的时刻，我会在Instagram上发一张小方图。
I say, do you have any questions about such and such an episode?
我说，大家对某某集有什么问题吗？
But then I make a little joke and a little inside joke taken from that episode.
但随后我开了一个小玩笑，一个从那一集中提取的小内部笑话。
So that's a fun bit of writing that they get to do.
所以那是他们可以做的一段有趣的写作。
And then, I mean, it goes on and on, and then I have to edit it, and then within the editing process, there's three different, four different programs I'm using while I'm doing it.
然后，我的意思是，它没完没了，接着我必须编辑它，在编辑过程中，我一边做一边使用了三四个不同的程序。
And by the way, as I feel every day, the train does not stop.
顺便说一句，正如我每天所感受到的那样，列车从不停歇。
Every Monday comes and a new episode has to happen.
每个星期一都会到来，必须有一集新节目推出。
So I'm editing an episode, planning for the next one, we're going to record, thinking about the fact that I have three others in the hopper that need to be edited and then also, oh, what about next season?
所以我正在剪辑一集，为下一集做计划，我们要录音，脑子里想着我还有另外三集在待办箱里需要剪辑，然后还有，哦，下一季呢？
I mean, there's 200 episodes of this show.
我的意思是，这个节目有200集。
There's no end to when I have to stop thinking in advance of what's gonna happen next.
对于我什么时候必须停止提前思考接下来会发生什么，是没有尽头的。
And then, you know, it's producing and like editing is such a, it disappears, right?
然后，你知道，它是制作类的，而且剪辑是如此的，它会消失，对吧？
When you listen to the podcast, I guess the hope.
当你听播客时，我想这就是希望所在。
I guess one says that the hope is you're not thinking about a single thing that I, Alec, have done on this show, right?
我想有人会说，希望是你不会去想我，亚历克，在这个节目中所做的任何事情，对吧？
And it's my goal to make you not think about that.
我的目标就是让你不去想这些。
And it's my goal to make the hosts not think about that.
我的目标是让主持人们也不去想这些。
I just want them to have this place where they can do their best work in front of the microphone and then have that get out to the world.
我只希望他们能拥有这样一个地方，在那里他们可以在麦克风前展现出最好的工作状态，然后将其推向世界。
And so what I do disappears and the editing kind of disappears, but it's very satisfying on those Mondays when the episode is posted.
所以我所做的事情消失了，剪辑也算是消失了，但在那些周一节目发布的时候，它是非常令人满足的。
And even though I've heard it five times by then, you pick up your phone and it's just sitting, no, it's just there.
尽管到那时我已经听过五遍了，但你拿起手机，它就静静地躺在那儿，不，它就在那儿。
It's just one, there's no more nothing.
它就是这样一个，再也没有别的什么了。
You gotta do to it.
你不需要再对它做任何事。
It's just sitting there on your phone.
它就静静地躺在你的手机上。
And that's a very satisfying moment.
这是一个非常令人满足的时刻。
Yes, we have a very ephemeral job often.
是的，我们的工作通常非常短暂。
Yeah, certainly ephemeral to paint with the right word, media, medium, the stuff that I'm doing, the stuff that you're doing here, that we're clicking away just constantly is not the work, is not the physical work of art that anyone's looking at kind of sort of.
是的，短暂绝对是个合适的词，媒体，媒介，我正在做的事，你在这里正在做的事，我们不断点击出来的东西，并不是那种别人会看的实体艺术品，差不多是这样。
It totally is and it totally is it.
它完全是，它也完全不是。
Right, there's that difference between the art of the making, you know, it's all the chips of marble on the floor versus the statue of David which you actually see at the end.
对吧，制作的艺术之间存在着那种区别，你知道的，这就像是地上的所有大理石碎屑，而你最终看到的是大卫像。
And you don't look at the sculpture and think about the rectangle it used to be.
而你看着雕塑时，不会去想它曾经是一个长方体。
Right.
对。
You know, that kind of thing.
你知道，就是那种感觉。
You know, he also has, I'm gonna get myself in trouble of telling you to talk about art at all, but he's also got those statues of the figures that are still coming out of the stone.
你知道，他还拥有——我真不该让你谈论艺术的——但他还有那些仍在从石头中挣脱出来的雕像。
It's in the same museum as David.
就在收藏《大卫》的那家博物馆里。
And I totally took to those.
我完全被那些吸引住了。
And now thinking about like what I do with my life dolly making stuff, but I also am a constant stream of making behind the scenes stuff of the stuff I'm making, because I'm fascinated by that.
现在回想起来，就像我用自己的人生做娃娃、做东西一样，我也一直在源源不断地制作我所做东西的幕后花絮，因为我对那很着迷。
And so the idea that I like that I saw those 20 years ago, I'm now putting this together.
所以20年前我看到那些雕像的想法，我现在把它们串联起来了。
I like the statues leaving the marble, because I like the behind the scenes of it.
我喜欢那些从大理石中脱颖而出的雕像，因为我喜欢它的幕后过程。
I get to still see that.
我还能看到那些。
That's interesting.
这很有趣。
How do you know when something that you're making is done, or if it's resisting being done?
你怎么知道你正在创作的东西什么时候算完成，或者它是否在抗拒完成？
It's a great moment.
这是一个美妙的时刻。
You do need to decide that it's done.
你确实需要决定它完成了。
I mean, I guess one doesn't.
我的意思是，我想也可以不用。
And it's, you know, you listen, read stories and we're on Try Now's book on Da Vinci to read about the Mona Lisa of like 15 years of painting over and over and over and over and over but then he stopped at some point and so I guess no you don't ever have to have to stop there's a church in New York on 110th Street it's part of the mission is that it's never done and so it is always being it is always being remodeled in some way refurbished in some way but I love it I love when you're editing.
而且，你知道的，你听过、读过很多故事，我们在读沃尔特·艾萨克森写的关于达芬奇的书时，了解到他花了大约15年的时间不断地在《蒙娜丽莎》上涂改、涂改、涂改、涂改、再涂改，但后来他在某个时刻停了下来，所以我想，不，你其实永远不必非得停下来，纽约110街有一座教堂，它的宗旨之一就是它永远不会完工，所以它总是在以某种方式被改造、以某种方式被翻新，但我就是喜欢，我喜欢当你处于剪辑状态时。
And so let's say that two people have said something.
比方说，两个人说过一些话。
Person A says something, person B says something.
A说了一些话，B说了一些话。
But at the end of person A's sentence, there's some gibberish, something garbled, and you can't use that.
但在A的句子结尾处有一些胡话、一些含糊不清的声音，你不能用它。
So you have to edit that out.
所以你必须把它剪掉。
Now you have to make it sound like these two people spoke to each other.
现在你必须让这两个人听起来像是在互相交谈。
But the part in the middle where the actual overlap is gone.
但中间实际重叠的部分已经没了。
So now I need to make a new overlap.
所以现在我需要制造一个新的重叠。
I need to make it sound like this conversation happen that way or just any edit in a movie someone's running in this direction then you cut to the next shot.
我需要让这段对话听起来就像原本就是那样发生的，或者就像电影中的任何剪辑一样，某人正朝这个方向跑，然后你切换到下一个镜头。
There's something when you when you make that edit happen you get those two clips next to each other and you figure out where one should end and one should stop and I might be right I might be wrong someone else might do it a different way but I definitely have a moment where I go that's exactly the way it should be that's it yeah I'm not changing and and when you're editing you're dealing with as little as one 24th of a frame and And there is a difference between moving it here or moving it one 24th of a frame over there and there's just something in me that goes I am done with this moment, which is not how I feel necessarily about writing words on a page that especially dialogue To that have you ever felt like a Project or a task is really More like making itself and you're kind of along for the ride or do you usually feel like you're definitely molding The thing yeah, I don't I've heard a lot of writers certainly talk about that the characters are sort of starting to speak For themselves and you're a bit along for the right.
当你进行这种剪辑、把这两个片段放在一起时，你会找出其中一个应该在哪里结束、另一个应该在哪里停止，我可能是对的，我也可能是错的，别人可能会用不同的方式来做，但我绝对有一个瞬间，我会觉得：“就是这样，这就是它该有的样子，就是这样，没错，我再也不改了”，而且当你在剪辑时，你处理的单位小至二十四分之一帧，而把它放在这里和把它往那边移动二十四分之一帧是有区别的，我内心深处就是有某种东西会告诉我“我对这个时刻完成了”，这和我在纸上写字时的感觉不完全一样，特别是对话，你有没有觉得某个项目或任务其实更像是在自我成型，而你只是顺其自然，还是说你通常觉得自己确实在塑造这个东西？是的，我没有——我当然听很多作家说过那样的话，说角色开始自己说话了，而你只是顺其自然。
I guess I'm just I'm not that mystical a fella And I don't really see things that way.
我想我只是——我不是那么神秘主义的人，我真的不那样看问题。
I'm open to it being that way But no, I do feel like I'm I'm pulling a pulling or pushing when I'm making something or when we are making something, we the collective, we are literally you and me and our other collaborators, I feel like it's us doing the thing, making the thing.
我倒是不排斥顺其自然，但说实话，每当我或者我们在创作的时候——这里的“我们”是个集体，字面意思就是你、我和其他合作者——我确实感觉这是我们在共同完成、创作一件事。
But I think I get into that flow pretty quickly because I'm so desirous of starting, of working.
但我认为我能很快进入那种心流状态，因为我太渴望开始了，太渴望工作了。
I mean, when we hang up, I'm gonna jump back into something or other.
我的意思是，等我们挂了电话，我马上就会投入到这样或那样的事务中去。
Let's wrap this up.
我们快结束吧。
I'm not, I'm not, we have work to do.
我可不，我可不，我们还有工作要做。
Yes, as do I, yes, but I do think that getting to that state where you're really just in it comes swiftly and comes beautifully because the other things have been set up in such a way in an intelligent and capable way because you have done this for a long time, you actually and the real you have done this for a long time, whatever your thing is, and then you can gift yourself the chance to really just swim around.
是的，我也是，不过我的确觉得，当你真正进入那种完全投入的状态时，它会来得非常迅猛且美妙，因为其他事情已经以一种智能且干练的方式安排妥当了。正因为你长久以来一直在做这件事，你（真正意义上的你）长期以来都在从事你所热爱的不管什么行当，然后你才能给自己一份礼物，真正地去尽情畅游。
Right.
没错。
And so to that, I think there's kind of the two sides of art making or thing doing.
因此对于这一点，我认为艺术创作或做事大概有两个方面。
How do you like that?
你觉得这样说怎么样？
Where it's...
那就是……
It was at the Alteredame of this podcast.
这成了这个播客的代名词。
Yes, I do.
没错，我是这么觉得。
I'm on a shield marker is thing doing.
我得修正一下，这叫“做事”。
Just, it's actually the craft of thing doing.
准确地说，其实是“做事”的技艺。
It's still, and that part of anyone's creative process or use of those muscles can be more structural and some can be more loosey goosey and they can go exist.
而且，任何人创作过程中的这一部分，或者对这些能力的运用，可以更有条理性，也可以更随性，它们是可以共存的。
I think they completely coexist.
我认为它们完全可以共存。
You will remember that there was a scene we were doing during our California Connect where we were doing these short videos with these communication devices, where the scene took place in a theater, we were shooting in a theater, and the idea was that rehearsals for a show were going on.
你肯定还记得我们在加州联创时拍过的一个场景，当时我们正用这些通讯设备拍短片，场景发生在一个剧院里，我们在一个剧院里拍摄，而设定是某个演出正在进行彩排。
And there of course was no show, we were just approximating, we were saying, okay, we're doing Midsummer Night's Dream, but of course we didn't stage Midsummer Night's Dream at all.
当然现场并没有什么演出，我们只是在模拟，我们说，好吧，我们在排《仲夏夜之梦》，但当然我们根本没有真正排练《仲夏夜之梦》。
So there were three or four actors on stage, hour actors who were then playing actors who were characters in the show.
所以舞台上有三四个演员，他们是真正的演员，但在剧中扮演着角色的演员。
We like stuff like this.
我们就喜欢这种调调。
And so I'm directing this and it's, we're going to basically just, all I need is a lot of shots of it looking like you're rehearsing a show, but you're not.
于是我来导演这个场景，基本上，我只需要大量的镜头，拍出你们在排练节目的样子，但其实并不是。
You don't know where to go.
你们甚至不知道该往哪走。
And I just wasn't going to block.
我压根不打算去设计走位。
I wasn't going to sit there and take an hour to go, okay, you walk here, you walk here, work it out.
我才不会坐在那儿花上一小时说：“好，你走到这儿，你走到那儿，琢磨一下。”
Add to the fascination here is our director photography, our mutual friend, Ruan, who is deaf, he was on the camera, he was operating the camera.
更绝的是我们的摄影指导，我们的共同好友阮（Ruan），他是聋哑人，他在负责掌镜，操作摄像机。
And he and I planned absolutely zero whatsoever.
我和他之间可以说是零计划，完全没有排练。
And so what we do is we just let the camera run for 10 minutes.
所以我们做的就是让摄像机连续运行10分钟。
And he and I are running around like lunatics.
我和他就像两个疯子一样到处跑。
I believe you actually were interpreting in the moment for him.
我记得当时你其实一直在为他做即时翻译。
But I don't even know that he was watching much of what you were doing.
但我甚至不知道他有没有怎么看你的手势。
We were I was just screaming out to the actors.
我们……我当时只是在大声冲演员喊。
Okay.
好吧。
Of course, I don't remember anyone's name now or then, but we'll call them John.
当然，我当时和现在都不记得任何人的名字了，我们就暂且管他叫约翰。
John, you walk down left.
约翰，你往舞台左侧走。
Okay, now crossover and her now she said, and it's like, okay, I use my theater, my theater director brain to be staging a play while guiding a camera to come over here and go over there.
好，现在交叉走位，还有她，现在她……这就好像，好吧，我用我作为一个戏剧导演的大脑，一边在排演一出戏，一边引导摄像机镜头“到这儿来”、“去那儿去”。
And that was using all those, all the things all at once in a distinctly ordered, a distinctly ordered chaos.
那是在一种分明有序、井然的混乱中，同时运用了所有的这一切。
I do remember that.
我还真记得那事。
I was interpreting, but what's, what stood out to me then, and I remember now and I'm reminded in this moment, is that Ruan also seemed to instinctively go where things needed to go.
我当时确实在做翻译，但让我感触最深、至今仍记忆犹新并在此时被唤醒的是，阮似乎也能本能地知道镜头该去向哪里。
I was certainly not facilitating the communication really at all.
我其实根本没有发挥什么沟通桥梁的作用。
And I think that speaks to both of you having a really strong, it's kind of like an eye for storytelling and the movement.
我觉得这说明你们两个都有着非常敏锐的直觉，有点像是对讲故事和运动轨迹的敏锐眼光。
Like you both understood from communicating about it and some generally beforehand, we need to capture the feeling of this space, the movement of this space and these people.
就像你们通过之前的交流以及一些大致的沟通，心里都有数：我们需要捕捉这个空间的氛围、这个空间的运动感，以及这些人的状态。
It needs to feel like this.
它必须呈现出这种感觉。
and then you just made it happen.
然后你们就直接把它实现了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
I'm both a planner, clearly, definitely.
我这人既是个规划者，这很明显，毋庸置疑。
My spreadsheets have spreadsheets, but I think what I want to do is plan all the way up to a certain moment and then let the plan trust that the scaffolding is there, the structures.
我的电子表格里面还有电子表格，但我觉得我想做的是，把计划做到某个特定节点，然后相信这个计划，相信脚手架和结构已经搭好了。
where everyone also has the skills to perform in the moment.
每个人也都具备在当下发挥出色的技能。
And then the fun part is the question marks, right?
然后有趣的部分就是那些问号了，对吧？
It's not as much fun to say, okay, now you specifically, I want you to take four steps over there.
如果对别人说：“好了，现在具体到你，我要你往那边走四步”，那就没那么有意思了。
I mean, you could work that way.
我的意思是，你当然也可以那样工作。
And that's why no plans this weekend.
这就是为什么这周末没有计划。
And the podcast too is just less, okay, I got it, the stage is set.
播客也是，就是少一点，好吧，我明白了，舞台已经搭好了。
I have set the stage for y'all.
我已经为你们大家搭好舞台了。
And then do your thing.
然后做你们的事。
whether it's Josh or Craig doing their thing for an hour or a bunch of actors doing something in front of a camera for a couple of minutes, that's a joy for me is the stuff I could not possibly have planned and I just get to sit back and watch it.
无论是乔什还是克雷格在做他们持续一小时的事，还是一群演员在镜头前表演几分钟，对我来说最大的乐趣在于那些我完全无法预先计划的东西，而我只需坐下来观看。
Yeah.
是的。
This comes up so often with people that I talk to about the way that they have retooled what is a more freeform creative self into a more career-based creative self, that there is the same word comes out.
我和许多人交流时经常遇到这种情况，他们谈到自己如何将更加自由奔放的创意自我重新调整为更具职业导向的创意自我时，都会说出同一个词。
There's this scaffolding in place, there's some structure in place because when you have that there, then you can have also the more play part where you could be a little bit more experimental in what you're doing and you say, ah, that doesn't really work, but it's okay because you have all the shelves of other options there.
这里有一个现成的支架，有一些现成的结构，因为有了这些，你就可以有更多玩乐的部分，在做的事情上可以更加随性、更具实验性，你可以说，啊，那个其实不太行，但没关系，因为旁边还有满满一架子的其他备选项。
And there is also a certain self-trust necessary to say, I built a good skeleton here.
同时，这也需要一定的自信，去相信：我在这里建立了一个很好的骨架。
Great.
太棒了。
Now we can kind of dress it up and that's applicable in so many different creative paths, career paths.
现在我们可以对其进行一番装扮了，这适用于许多不同的创意道路和职业道路。
It's also very sad.
这也非常悲伤。
You know, it's like a soup on the house.
你知道的，就像店里的招牌汤一样。
You know, for no plans, we really just shot what was there.
你知道，对于《没有计划》，我们其实就是抓拍了当时呈现的东西。
Yes, you did not have a huge amount to do.
是的，你其实不需要做太多事情。
In fact, you were planning I believe our next thing while you were sitting in the kitchen tapping away, but for the California Connect stuff, the beauty also for a director is to have a producer like you, where things appear.
事实上，我相信你在厨房里敲键盘时，就已经在规划我们的下一个项目了，不过对于“加州连线”的项目，对导演来说，最美妙的事情就是能有一个像你这样的制片人，东西自然而然就出现了。
It's so cool that you've made these plans, but as the director, I don't bring stuff anywhere.
你把这些计划都做好了，这太酷了，但作为导演，我不需要把任何东西带到现场。
I just blissfully show up, and when they're there, that's an incredibly inspiring creative moment that the tools you think you wanted were put there by someone that has the skills to put them there.
我只是高高兴兴地出现，当它们就在那里时，那真是一个极其鼓舞人心的创意时刻——你以为自己想要的工具，是被一个具备相应技能的人放在那里的。
And now I get to move them around, and someone else gets to play in front of them too.
现在我来调度它们，其他人也可以在它们面前尽情表演。
How would you describe, in your own words, the difference in is not exactly what I mean to say.
你将如何用你自己的话来描述……这不太是我真正想表达的意思。
I can only be me.
我只能是我自己。
How would you describe the difference in creativity and art in your own experience of a relationship to either of those things being not mutually exclusive?
在你对这两者的体验中，你如何描述创造力和艺术之间的区别？这两者并不是互不排斥的。
Sure.
当然。
I got it.
我懂了。
I got this one.
这个我来。
I think creativity is putting something new into the world.
我认为创造力就是为这个世界带来一些新的东西。
That's That's all, folks.
好了，好了，各位。
We'll see you later.
我们回头见。
Thanks, podcast.
谢谢你，播客。
That's the end, season one.
第一季到此结束。
We've solved it.
我们已经把它搞懂了。
The craft of thing-doing.
做事的手艺。
Season one.
第一季。
The craft of thing-doing is place of meaning to the world.
做事的手艺就是给世界赋予意义的地方。
It is.
确实如此。
And I guess that the, what I would suggest as not being art but being creative is any task you have at your job, say you're waiting tables and you do it a certain way.
我想，我要说的不属于艺术而是属于创造力的东西，就是你工作中的任何任务，比如说你在端盘子，而你用某种特定的方式去做。
And then you realize, oh, if I walk around this table that way, or if I'm literally collecting the plates, I should stack it this way.
然后你意识到，哦，如果我以那种方式绕过这张桌子，或者如果我直接在收盘子时这样叠放。
That hasn't been done before, or this hasn't been done before by you, who cares if someone else has done it.
这以前没有人做过，或者这是你以前没有做过的，别人做没做过谁在乎呢。
It hasn't been done before you.
在你之前，这还没被做过。
So you've created a solution.
所以你创造了一个解决方案。
You've created a plan.
你制定了一个计划。
You have not just listened to what someone told you to do.
你不仅仅是听从别人的吩咐去做事。
You haven't just copied what someone told you to do.
你不仅仅是复制别人告诉你该做的事。
You have made something new.
你创造了新的东西。
But I think art, a piece of art has a kind of unity to it, to all of its parts are telling the same story or all of its parts are actively telling disparate stories, if that is the story you want to tell.
但我认为艺术，一件艺术品有一种统一性，它的所有部分都在讲述同一个故事，或者如果这就是你想讲的故事的话，它的所有部分都在积极地讲述不同的故事。
But there is a big spiritual, philosophical, temporal, beginning, middle, and end to your work of art that you have created as compared to a solution, a spreadsheet, a path taken, a way to sell something, a way to walk, a way to think that is creating, but not art.
但是，与解决方案、电子表格、走过的路、某种销售方式、某种行走方式、某种思考方式（这些属于创造，但并非艺术）相比，你所创作的艺术品具有一种宏大的精神上的、哲学上的、时间的、有头有尾的统一性。
Yes.
是的。
Good.
很好。
I do.
我是这么认为的。
Yeah.
对。
How'd I do?
我表现得怎么样？
You do.
你表现得。
Great.
太棒了。
That's great.
Do I get to get to clip that on the internet?
我能把这个剪辑下来发到网上吗？
Is that on the internet?
这会被发到网上吗？
It will be.
会的。
Yes.
是的。
I love that.
我太喜欢这个了。
I think about these differences all the time and where that line is and how to describe the the conversation that a work of art might be trying to suggest to the world by being viewed or consumed in some way versus the creative solution of a logistical profession or even a spreadsheet there's I I work with someone now who I will say I need these nine things to be possible in a sheet and he'll go okay and he'll create formulas where it's all speaking to each other and I just go, wow, that's awesome.
我一直在思考这些差异，那条分界线在哪里，以及如何去描述——一件艺术品通过某种方式被观看或消费，可能试图向世界表达的对话，相比之下，那种后勤类职业的创造性解决方案，甚至是电子表格……我现在和一个这样的人合作，我会对他说，我需要表格里有这九种功能，然后他会说好的，接着他会编写公式让它们彼此关联，而我只会感叹，哇，这太厉害了。
Is there a creative skill set that you don't have but you are interested in learning or growing more in?
有没有什么你目前不具备、但你有兴趣学习或进一步提升的创意技能？
I would say that directly related to the work I do, I made a film called What, which is a silent film with deaf actors and I really did it, especially I could in borrowing from a tradition of silent black and white films that pretty much use master shots, just wide shots of people in the frame.
我想说，直接与我的工作相关的是，我曾拍过一部名为《什么》的电影，那是一部由聋哑演员出演的默片，我确实拍出来了，尤其是我尽可能地借鉴了黑白默片传统的拍摄手法，那些片子基本都使用主镜头，也就是画面中人物的广角镜头。
They're performing on stage for you in the cameras there to show you that.
他们在舞台上为你表演，而摄像机就在那里为你展现这一切。
Then the next one when we did no plans this weekend, there's some cinematic choices made there but we're really trying to just capture the comedians saying the things and still that was pretty much wide shots of people talking.
然后接下来当我们制作《这周末没有计划》时，里面做了一些电影层面的选择，但我们实际上只是试图捕捉喜剧演员们说的话，即便如此，基本上还是人物交谈的广角镜头。
Like we didn't really do a a lot of not that many close-ups here they are.
就像我们并没有真正拍很多——没有拍那么多特写镜头，它们就在那里。
We really do that many close-ups, but we did some here and there.
我们确实没有拍那么多特写镜头，但这里和那里也拍了一些。
I would say that this next one what we want to do, I want it to be nothing less than the most beautiful movie ever made.
我想说，接下来我们要拍的这部，我希望它成为有史以来最美丽的电影，没有之一。
So I'm gonna have some work to get done between now and there.
所以从现在到开拍之间，我还有很多工作要做。
You're aiming to keep now and then drop off.
你的目标是立足当下然后不断突破。
Okay.
好的。
Great.
太棒了。
So that that's something is really ingesting some movies in the style, ingesting some art in the style that opens my brain up a little more to how to use that camera, to tell a beautiful story beautifully.
所以，这需要大量观看这种风格的电影，欣赏这种风格的艺术，让我的大脑进一步开窍，去思考如何运用摄像机，把一个美好的故事优美地讲述出来。
Well, I'm rooting for you.
好吧，我支持你。
I think so.
我想是的。
Great.
太棒了。
This has been great.
这次访谈太棒了。
Thank you for talking to me about this and all the things that you do.
谢谢你和我聊这些，还有你所做的所有事情。
And all of the, I'm really, I admire the fact that you are able to so freely go between a lot of order and structure into allowing yourself to enjoy that for yourself in all the fun ways.
而且，我真的很佩服你能够如此自如地在严谨的秩序与结构，以及让自己以各种有趣的方式享受这一切之间自由切换。
And then before we go, you might as well tell us for the third time what you're up to, where we can find it and how we can support the show.
在结束之前，你不妨第三次告诉我们你在忙些什么、在哪里可以找到这些内容以及我们该如何支持这个节目。
the show.
这个节目。
Sure.
当然。
How we made your mother is available everywhere.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史是怎么拍的》各大平台均可收听。
Super fun podcast.
超级有趣的播客。
If you're a fan of how I met your mother, start watching again and listen along with us.
如果你是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的粉丝，那就重新开始看，并和我们一起收听。
If you've never seen it, this is your time to get started.
如果你从未看过，现在就是你开始的好时机。
Start from the beginning and we are going episode by episode.
从头开始，我们将逐集进行讨论。
And the show is not quite a scene by scene breakdown.
这个节目不仅仅是对每集剧情的逐场景剖析。
It's kind of a what is this episode talking about and Josh and Craig made this in their 30s and now they're in their early 50s and they're thinking about life very differently and art very differently and thinking about what they made back then in a new way and so I think it's exciting to listen to for that reason and how we majormother.com it's all right there.
它有点像是在探讨这一集在讲什么，乔什和克雷格在三十多岁时制作了这部剧，而现在他们刚过五十岁，他们对生活的看法和对艺术的看法已经大不相同，他们以一种全新的方式看待自己当年创作的作品，所以我觉得出于这个原因，听这个节目会让人感到很兴奋，howimetyourmother.com，一切都在那里。
Check out what WHAT question mark is on all the things.
去关注一下带问号的《什么》，各大平台都有。
I think I think you can get it on, you buy it from Apple and watch it in various places, I don't actually know, Amazon, something like that.
我想你可以在苹果购买并在各种地方观看，其实我也不太确定，亚马逊什么的，诸如此类。
And then we'll just stay tuned, just stay tuned for what comes next.
然后大家就拭目以待，敬请期待接下来会有什么。
All right, well we'll do this again after we make our next movie.
好吧，等我们拍完下一部电影后再来做这个节目。
Just keep running credits and things for people to keep their eye on.
只要继续滚动播放演职员表和各种信息，让大家持续关注就行了。
Excellent.
太好了。
The craft of being is produced and hosted by me.
《做事的手艺》由我制作并主持。
Music is wide-eyed by Colin O'Brien Lux.
片头曲是科林·奥布莱恩·拉克斯（Colin O'Brien Lux）的《广阔的视野》（Wide-eyed）。
Big thanks as always to my dogs for barking through these six minutes of every single recording session, definitely check out the show notes for Collins Bandcamp, more about today's guest, their links and socials and anything else we mentioned on the show, and if you want to get in touch, come find me on Instagram at The Craft of Being, or send me an email at thecraftofbeingpod at gmail.com.
一如既往，非常感谢我的狗狗们，在每一次长达六分钟的录音过程中一直在狂吠，一定要去节目简介里查看科林的Bandcamp主页、关于今天嘉宾的更多信息、他们的链接和社交账号以及我们在节目中提到的其他任何内容，如果你想取得联系，可以在Instagram上搜索“做事的手艺”找到我，或者发邮件至thecraftofbeingpod@gmail.com。
Thanks for being here and until next time.
感谢大家的收听，我们下期再见。